è la tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono la vj ed oggi siamo
tornati su inside avevo fatto un
bordello della madonna per arrivare a
questo punto tutto lo scorso episodio
continua a esserci in tutto questo
edificio è enorme questa sottospecie di
terremoto come se ci fosse qualcuno di
gigante che cammina dietro questa porta
ecco infatti scopriamo cosa ho sentito
la porta al numero uno
ci siete ragazzi diavolo è è la madonna
cos'è quest'anno bombardare ma non è un
gigante stanno bombardando chi sta
bombardando cosa fatemi capire
porca [ __ ]
corri veloce non è vero non è successo
quello che ho visto devo correre da un
riparo all'altro sono miz molecole
meraviglioso veloce veloce della luce
porca vacca solo fare quando tirava leva
perfetto vai veloce veloce tira miyake
ansia ma devo tirare tipo la leva al
contrario perfetto mai mai mai ma non ce
l'ho ce l'ho ce l'ho fatta ci ho
ripensato mi carlo addosso cos'è sta
roba che sta bombardando cosa come cos'è
sta cosa succedendo
va bene si scoprirà prima perché la sta
succedendo spero
eccolo è un riparo va bene
cazzo madonna che tempismo dall'arpac e
ciò che devo fermarla che ne so
michele anche così sono un rincoglionito
si cazzo ok ok adesso il teorema come
cazzo faccio a saperlo
ok deve andare mi di culo cedeva devo
avere un culo assurdo in teoria perfetto
vai veloce non ci credo ma funzionato
sul serio
va bene ok non ho capito come ho fatto
ma va bene così tempismo è il mio
secondo nome tempismo mi chiama lorenzo
tempismo ostuni ok vai veloce effetto
più nei settori salvo che non fatta
ragazzi non ho capito niente cos'era sta
roba giorno quella era la mia classe a
scuola uguale ragazzi miei compagni di
classe e quello sono io è tra che faccio
tiro l'aveva merda ti giuro che non
volevo ve lo giuro
ed allora non si fanno un cazzo non vale
ma non si fanno niente sfide fisciano
uno è caduto uno è caduto ciano una
specie di tuta che gli permette di
sopravvivere a sta cosa posso averne una
anch'io per favore grazie questo momento
mi servirebbe un sacco
e vabbè mica suonano pezzi dico volo
anch'io ho detto vai veloce purché
ma dai minchia fa chi è a ragazzi ce
l'ho fatta
mica per un attimo penso di esser morto
non ho ben capito come funziona ma
proviamoci jolo jolo jolo
che culo vai vai vai vai se non ci credo
ma a volte mi vanno ecco perfetto orca
shira io devo stare zitto ma questo non
ho capito che devo stare zitto comunque
ragazzi ho capito è abbastanza semplice
come soluzione ma io sono stupido ok
perfetto bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
vice keita fratello ce l'ho fatta è
incredibile regala stanno sganciando
nucleari di continuo cos'è sta roba
quasi quasi preferivo la tizia a quella
del sottomarino al piano perfetto
disastro lega non ci voglio credere
non è che proprio mi mi dà sicurezza sto
ascensore tutto sgangherato prova bene
perché dobbiamo andare sempre sempre
sotto in basso nelle cose siamo al
centro della terra un altro top
[Musica]
di pino sto zitto nella di perché io
parlo sempre porta leila avete notato
che negli ascensori c'è sempre qualcosa
che clicchi e chiama l'assistenza ecco
non credo che in questo caso funzioni
bene frate 6 nella merda tanto per
cambiare esodo fare o affogare niente il
mio compito è solo e unicamente quello
di morire qua dentro
ok ok ci ho fatta trovata non ci
arriverò mai muoio prima e invece ho
fatta ce l'ho fatta stava per affogare
ma non è affogato va bene a prosto zio
se volevo imitare vomita tranquillo
senza capire chi era la bambina senza
capire chi è che bombarda senza capire
niente vado avanti però l'agilità non
l'hai persa nei sei stanco ma stai calma
non è che mi entra godzilla o bombardano
di nuovo non sembra devi fare veloce
veloce veloce perfetto no basta acqua
ragazzi basta perché questo gioco lo
passo metà in acqua perchè sono messi a
fare gli sviluppatori visto gioco erano
mezze sirene perché non è possibile
infatti usciti ogni volta che entrò
nell'acqua ciò la fobia che mi esca la
tipa di prima fantastico devo andare
tipo lo sapevo lo sapevo azzi a cosa le
hanno infilato ne hanno ma questa è
un'altra non è quella di prima di
importante che non ti svegli poi per il
resto che sarò là a ok ho capito fermi
allora faccio prima così poi così poi
vado qua sopra
aspetto che l'altra
ok
nicchia fantastico ma ogni tanto mi
stupisco di me stesso ragazzi poche
volte mi capita ma quando capita tutta
la [ __ ] sotto casa mia dove che dobbiamo
andare
l'importante che non svegliamo la tizia
tanto so già come andrà a finire non c'è
bisogno che ok se mi butto qua sopra in
teoria dovrei finirci proprio sopra è
bello questo gioco come lo amo stai
calma è calma zia calma però tanto muoio
affogato prima lo sapevo se mossa
porcaccia eva puntano su cazzola vivo
sono vivo bene murray attaccato a questa
corda per il resto della tua vita fra
tema quindi era sveglia non stava
dormendo si scada hmi lo slancio giusto
in teoria riesco guadagnare metri di
vantaggio vai bene bene mere vede bene
la cena cielo già perfetto perfetto
perfetto lurida stocco la sono fatta
bene nei processi si stacca la scala
sono morto
e invece no fantastico ragazzo l'ansia
solo quando la tipa non lo so perché mi
mette ansia i bombardamenti non mi
mettevano ansia la tipa sì non so perché
se sta roba
c'è una porta di sotto la vedo entra
veloce veloce veloce veloce chiedilo a
porta ti prego tutto nel culo tutto dai
ragazzi va ai ragazzi incredibile hanno
ancora successo che mi ha preso non ci
posso credere mai vai vai vai vai veloce
veloce veloce madonna quanto già miche
bruttissimo è bruttissimo e schiaccia fa
qualcosa
oddio che cazzo è le giostre a gardaland
questa roba è un uncino stato uncinare
devo agganciare qualcosa probabilmente
la tizia non lo so se vado avanti mi
sopra c'è qualcos'altro c'è
qualcos'altro
[Musica]
ma [ __ ] niente poi visto niente
ragazze erano capito cosa devo fare
un peccato perché non aveva preso ancora
neanche una volta non è che devo tipo
attirarla e poi saltare su sta cosa
credo bo tipo così si ma salta
deficiente anche salta avanti problemi
come c'è stranissimo questo cazzo [ __ ]
ok già fatta ce l'ho fatta bene credo
non lo so quindi adesso mi butto in
acqua e la tipa dovrebbe metterci troppo
a raggiungermi qui ce l'ho fatta si
spera veloce però veloce nei
recentissimi tigran cazzi
non ci vuole gara spiega fuoco al fuoco
affoga foro o malato il joystick ma se
non lo è se no a fuoco perfetto non ci
voglio credere
fantastico ci ho messo un ora per capire
come fare stare però ce l'ho fatta
l'importante questo bene ma crolla tutto
tanto per cambiare no fun bello quando è
così tranquillo non succede niente
niente bombardamenti niente godzilla
niente zombie c'è solo il volt di
fallout a si apre proprio fantastico no
no no ma bastava edizione quante palle
che mi hai rotto troppe quanto tempo mi
devi rincorrere tanto devo andare di
nuovo in acqua e allora che cosa mi è
cambiato veloce zio veloci zio
velocizzino
anche chi c'è in te deficiente porca eva
un deficiente c'è tremori wall pulsante
mentre lo primo vado nell'altra stanza
ok bravissimo eccolo che lo zucca bene
bravo ma o basta è non mi sono veramente
scassato i trequarti basta non ne voglio
più sapere i the della tipa dello
shampoo pantene non me ne frega un cazzo
ma stai non mi insegue più gente
l'importante quello che siamo
che eva ci manca basta che due [ __ ]
trasmetti mi sta portando juke brutta
[ __ ] cosa fai
posso non far ancora morto è non so
perché ancora però non sono ancora morto
come è possibile
niente è morto è morto ma non mi ha
fatto ancora iniziare non so perché si
sta roba quanto sprofondando che brutta
cosa non la voglio vedere è orribile
[Musica]
in realtà ragazzi visto che questa cosa
dell'oceano profondo e un mio incubo mi
sono pure messo il pigiama perché
stanotte cielo nel culo vabbè creati con
quello che l'episodio spero che il video
vi sia piaciuto stiamo arrivando verso
la fine ma non è finita qui però non
visse poi loro niente 50.000 pollici
super il prossimo episodio con clock i
ragazzi storia vera dushevina musica
bisogno di un commento è un mi piace uno
solo non due
perché non potete sono a mettetene 2
fate il cazzo che volete anche a pacelli
facebook e come nei video tale
descrizione cioè avvertiti capisci vi
diamo un prossimo video e ragazzi odio
l'acqua oceano del cat